the president is celebrating political
success after three states held
primaries yesterday his chosen candidate
won a closely watched Senate nomination
battle in Alabama at O'Keefe is covering
campaign 2020 and the president was very
pleased is this kind of a vindication
for mr. Trump well we'll see Anthony
good morning political newcomer Tommy
Tuberville prevailed in Alabama's GOP
Senate primary yesterday over former US
Attorney General Jeff Sessions sessions
of course was a key supporter of the
president's 2016 election but Trump was
backing Tuberville the former Auburn
University football coach in part
because he's been at odds with sessions
ever since he recused himself from the
investigation into Russian election
interference remember that Tuberville
now faces senator doug jones the most
vulnerable Senate Democrat up for
reelection in November elsewhere on the
campaign trail Democratic presidential
candidate Joe Biden once again slamming
the president for his response to the
coronavirus quit pushing the false
choice between protecting our health and
protecting our economy do your job mr.
president because if we can't deal with
the public health crisis we can't deal
with the economic crisis Biden is now
also pushing a two trillion dollar clean
energy and infrastructure plan that he
says would help reboot the economy after
the pandemic Biden said his plans would
help create millions of new jobs in the
auto industry and through government
backed construction projects and in a
nod to Liberal Democrats pushing for
more aggressive climate change proposals
Biden for the first time is calling for
a carbon-free power sector within the
next 15 years polls continue to show
Biden keeping it close with the
president in key swing states like
Arizona Florida and Texas
Tony the Biden campaign now so confident
about its chances in the Lone Star State
it's starting to spend money there on TV
advertising all right thank you very
much